what is it actually like making a movie
with Tom Cruise because he is one of the
most famous people on the planet I think
I think why he's the most famous person
on the planet is that he is at the top
of his game and has been for so long
because he's so committed to making
movies for the audience and so working
with him you're you're meeting every day
someone who turns up on set on time
knowing everyone's name saying hello to
everyone looking them in the eye seeing
what everyone needs to make sure that
they can Thrive that day
and you feel his level of
professionalism and commitment is
contagious and he always is pushing
himself he never settles and so that's
why he is the way he is and he wears his
Fame with such an ease and such a
likeness of touch and such an
open-heartedness you know he's a he's a
really he's a pure Soul Tom I think he's
just a really special human being yeah
he's also a professional because I've
been doing this for 18 years and there
are like you know some of the different
actors will do an hour of prayers like
or they want to press but like Tom is a
professional you know what I mean well
he knows that you know you guys are
coming to see the movies he's making and
he's making them for you so he that
connection that he has you know when we
were filming even these stunts in Rome
in a car he would get out in between
takes and setups and go and say hi to
everyone you know he he takes such
enjoyment from meeting people that come
and see his films because it's a
relationship it's a dialogue you know
and it's it's really it's really
humbling to see I think that's why
people love him you know people have
that that Charisma is comes from he
makes people feel seen
so I'm curious you have obviously worked
for Marvel and you've worked Mission
Impossible and Marvel like the movies
you made with Marvel were earlier but is
there any comparison to like a Marvel
movie to a mission movie like I mean
besides the basics of filmmaking because
it seems like they're they're different
but I I'm just curious well
it's almost you could I could it's like
also comparing it to
doing an Epson play in the West End or a
period drama adaptation of Ian Foster
novel which I've also done check it out
uh
in that they become you know every
filmmaker or group of people they there
is an understood structure of
Storytelling in places very similar but
but there is such a different aesthetic
taste a different process of filming
into the different challenges or
obstacles of filming any kind of story
is so unique and so you can't I can't
really compare I think the one thing
that has been consistent for me though
is is approaching each job with the same
level of um commitment and a work ethic
of making sure that I'm doing the best
that I possibly can and also challenging
myself to develop my own craft because I
have no intention to repeat old ground I
don't I don't want to bore the audience
too much I bought myself enough as it is
last thing for you yes um I would
imagine you shot a lot of videos on your
phone while you were shooting this is
there one that is your favorite oh my
gosh there are quite a few
um
I have a few of Tom playing heads up
that with Macquarie and he's only he you
know we did the movie category and he
would just say one word and I knew what
he was talking about his movie memory
history is like so fast and then I also
have a video of me putting on one of the
masks and hiding in Simon pegg's trailer
and scaring him over Halloween which I'm
sure will come out at some point yeah I
was gonna say one last thing that Fiats
do have flashbacks of of like anger or
you like that was the best time I can't
even look at it
now you're bringing up you've triggered
me Steve because you know it has a mind
of its own yeah we called it Trixie it's
like what is she gonna do today she's
unpredictable
um have a fantastic night